-You are the coolest.
I have so many things
to talk to you about.
Congrats on -- First of all,
Congrats on "This Is Why."
-Thank you.
-First album in --
Was it six years?
-Six years. Yeah.
-Yeah, and you came on our show,
and I appreciate that you guys
came on and performed.
We love you guys.
-That was so fun.
And now you're doing
"Re: This Is Why,"
which is "Remix."
Remix!
-Remix!
-Why did you end up doing this?
-So, it's not
a typical remix album.
We wanted to do something
where we could sort of connect
with bands that have inspired us
or bands that we've toured
with that
we really connected with
and give them a chance
to reinterpret the album.
-Yeah. I saw
The Linda Lindas on here.
-Yeah.
-Wet Leg.
-Mm-hmm. Romy from The xx.
Remi Wolf.
-Yeah.
-Bartees Strange.
-Panda Bear. Zane Lowe.
I mean, this is --
I mean, it's all fun.
-Yeah, it was such a fun --
It's very hard
to organize musicians.
-Yes.
-Like, we're not the easiest
people to -- You know?
-No, I do understand. Yeah.
-So this is a feat.
This is a miracle.
-You also brought us
some swag from your tour,
which I was excited about.
But can you explain
what I'm looking at?
-Oh, yeah. This shirt
was really popular on the tour.
So, these are my X-rays
from the chiropractor.
[ Laughter ]
I -- For the first 10 years of
our career, we would --
You know, we were always
the youngest band out,
and the older dudes
would be like,
"Oh, you're going to regret
headbanging like that."
And we were like,
"Nah, you're just really old."
And --
-Yeah, you're like,
"What up, old man?
Just get out of here."
-Yeah. And so, obviously,
I continued to headbang
and give myself whiplash
for a really long time.
And during the break
that we took,
which was -- We needed it so bad
and we really wanted
to take a break
just to kind of be home
and be kind of normal.
But I woke up one morning.
I, like,
couldn't look to my left
and I thought,
"It's time to pay the piper."
-Yeah. And, so, did you -- Was
something wrong with your neck?
-Yeah.
I know a lot about neck bones
at this point.
My cervical vertebrae,
C-5 and -6, were, like, eroding.
And I had what's called
military neck.
Like, I had, like, headbanged
the curvature out of my neck.
So it just became, like,
a huge part of my life.
-Does it come back?
-Well, I'm in, like,
serious P.T. all the time.
Like, on tour, I'm, like --
I'm trying to get swole
so that my neck can handle
the headbangs.
-You're going to continue
to headbang?
-I have to, Jimmy. It's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Absolutely not.
As your father, I'm telling you,
no more headbanging!
♪♪
No, don't you even start.
No rock music here.
How long have you guys
been together, you and the band?
-We --
-There's you guys.
-Aww, there we are.
-Taylor and Zac?
-Yeah. There we are.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Oh! Oh, wow, yeah.
-Who are these --
-That's --
-Who are these kids?
-So, this is when we met,
basically,
This was either 2002 or 2003.
We've been friends
a long time, man.
-Yeah, that's a long time.
-And you can see
our personalities vividly here.
Taylor stuck to the wall,
glued to the wall,
in the shadows, me posing,
Zac being a ham with
a farmer's tan, you can see.
-Yeah, he's got
a nice farmer's tan.
-This was Zac's favorite shirt.
He wore this for every --
I think he even wore it
in a music video.
But, yeah,
I was probably 14 here.
-And who are you listening to?
Who were your influences?
-Oh, at the time, we were
listening to Deftones a ton,
like, a lot of heavy music,
but -- And, like, Failure.
We loved failure.
But also -- Like,
I mean, I liked The Cure.
Like, I feel like we got
a pretty good music education.
But it's kind of funny.
Like, the first year
that we met,
there was a really huge hit
that kind of took over
our little homeschool
tutorial thing.
-And who was this?
-Do you know?
It's called "Idiot Boyfriend."
Do you know that song?
-My song?
-Yeah.
-My comedy song?
-"Idiot Boyfriend"?
-Huge hit with the
Paramore crew.
-I was the influence
for Paramore?
-Yes!
100%.
-100%?
-Yeah.
-My disc?
Really? "Idiot Boyfriend"?
-1,000%.
The music video -- iconic.
-That was Zooey Desch--
That was --
-Yes!
-I had a disco comedy song
when disco was at its peak.
2000, 2003.
-Yes. It was so good.
-No, it was not.
-Your falsetto.
-No. Where did you
even hear that song?
MTV.
-MTV, yes.
-They're only people
that would -- Thank you, MTV.
They're the only people that
ever played it ever once.
-Every morning,
getting ready for, like,
our homeschool thing --
It wasn't even, like,
really a school,
but it was --
We met up to do something
and, every morning, had MTV on.
And, like, your song
played more than, like --
I think John Mayer had a song
out of this at the same time.
-Yeah. Yeah, we have
similar careers, yeah.
-You got some spins, man.
-I got some spins in there.
-Yes.
-But look at you now.
Look at what I created.
Oh, my God. I am so happy.
"Re: This Is Why."
-Yeah.
-And then, next summer,
you're going to be opening up
for Taylor Swift
on her Eras Tour.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes.
-That's a big deal.
-Yeah.
But you've known each other
for a while, you and Tay--
-A long time.
Yeah, we kind of both
got started around the same time
and the same age, as well.
But, like, especially Nashville,
Nashville's very, like,
family, you know --
-I love Nashville.
-It's great.
I really like
our music community.
Everyone wants to help
each other out.
And, so, me and Taylor
met because both of us,
Paramore and Taylor, were
nominated for Best New Artist
the same year at the Grammys.
And, so, we were
at some Grammy party.
It was actually
Timbaland's Grammy party.
-Wow!
-Huge. I was very nervous.
But a woman came up to me
and she said,
"I'm Taylor Swift's mom.
And, you know,
Taylor doesn't have a lot of
friends her age that do music.
And I would love to,
like, you know,
introduce you guys
or get your number."
So Andrea, the legend
that she is, like --
-I love Taylor's mom.
-Yeah, me too.
-Yeah, she connected us and --
Yeah.
-Look, here you guys are.
-There we are.
Also, every photo of us
that's on the Internet,
one or both of us is like...
Like, I don't know why.
-That's your thing.
-It is our thing.
One of you -- Yeah.
-It's just to show
how cool we are.
It's like...
-Yeah, you don't
have to even do that anymore.
You're like, "Please."
We have the X-rays.
You're cool, alright?
Well, I'm so happy you're here.
Congrats on the album.
And I want you to be on our show
every album release.
-Oh, my God, please.
-Yeah.
And I was thinking about this,
because I saw the pre-interview,
and I was thinking,
if you wanted to,
maybe we can go out
to commercial
doing one of your
earliest influences,
if you wouldn't mind
singing with me.
-I would be honored.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ I know what you want ♪
♪ And I know what you need ♪
♪ But I'm gon' screw it up ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Because I'm an idiot ♪
♪ And I'm your boyfriend ♪
♪ Yes, I am ♪
-♪ And I'm gonna take you out ♪
♪ Leave my wallet home ♪
♪ Then I'll use
your cellphone, baby ♪
♪ Long distance ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm your boyfriend ♪
-Hayley Williams, everybody!
Come on!
That's what I'm talking about.
We'll be right back
with Maluma, everybody.
Come on back.
Oh!
♪ And I know what you need ♪
♪ Leave my wallet at home ♪
I can't believe you know this.
-[ Laughs ]